foreign
how did you find Tai Chi or how did Tai
Chi find you oh and there hangs a tail
so I was brought up
in a
fundamentalist Christian
extended family not just the nuclear
family the extended family
and it's only sort of later that I've
come to realize how traumatizing that
was for me and so when I was 15 I read a
couple of books Lord of Light and
Siddhartha Lord of Light by rajas alasni
stidharta by Hermann Hessa fifth
business by Robertson Davies and it
really blew me open it really blew me
open and so I left the Christianity
and I've
you know and like I said I've done some
therapy and other things but
religion your mother religion is like
your mother tongue right it shapes you
in a way that nothing else ever can or
your first love right you don't you
don't necessarily stay with that person
but it shapes you in very interesting
ways in in your relationships
and so if you'll allow me a metaphor
left a taste for the Transcendent in my
mouth but right
and then I got to University and I took
a first year course in philosophy and I
encountered the figure of Socrates and
the project of wisdom and it was like
that's it and of course that is still
with me now that's how profound it hit
me how profoundly
but what happened and then I went into
philosophy what happened in philosophy
academic philosophy now it's changing
now but we're talking about a long time
ago the 80s the topic of wisdom
self-transcendence all these kinds of
things that are rich in the platonic
corpuses like and the neoplatonic it
drops off the it drops off the table and
you talk about skepticism and
epistemology and these are valuable sort
of meta-scientific and metacultural
skills and I value them but that hunger
for the cultivation of wisdom was not
being met and I happened to live in a
place where literally down the road
there was the Tai Chi and meditation
center so I thought you know what I'm
going to give the Eastern philosophies a
try and maybe they will give me what I
need
for satisfying this hunger for the
cultivation of wisdom and and I was very
lucky again because first of all
wonderful people and secondly this is
where I got what I would Now call an
Ecology of practices they didn't teach
me one thing they taught me they taught
me a meditative practice the pasta they
taught me a contemplative practice meta
and then they taught me Tai Chi Chuan to
get how to flow between them in a
regular and reliable at this Ecology of
practices and it and that that's how it
happened and that has been with me ever
since wow
that is a very potent and
uncommon Trinity there that's a very
formidable combination of things and I
do want to revisit at some point
meditation as contrasted with
contemplation yes but first I'd like to
ask you how old were you when you
decided to leave Christianity and what
did that what was that experience like
oh
15. yeah and my life became bifurcated
and fragmented in a way that I came to
deeply find
distasteful and so trying to deal with
fragmentation has also become a
pervasive theme not whether it's a
fragmentation within a person or a
fragmentation between the different
disciplines that study the mind that's
why I'm in cognitive scientists trying
to integrate and solve the fragmentation
problem right
yeah it was very challenging for me
because
I I couldn't move out on my own or
anything I'm 15 right right I'm still in
my family and they had they knew that
something was going on and it was kind
of a like there was kind of this weird
don't ask don't tell thing it was very
challenging me there were times when I
went to church and you know the minister
would be getting everybody to Bow their
head and raise their hands if they
agreed with this and of course
everybody's looking around
surreptitiously and everybody's raising
their hand and I'm the one person not
raising my hand oh just very very
difficult and then of course I had a
group of friends those friends at high
school they became very much invested in
this project that I was engaged in of
wrestling with meaning and they really
and so they became very supportive and
that was very happy for me but that was
you know and it caused things and
it caused me to Get Married Too Young
right because marrying was a way of
escaping
that that fundamentalist family and
setting up a new one and
[Music]
um
and I'm on good terms with my ex I'm not
making any criticisms of her I'm just
saying we we got married I think too
young because we were both escaping that
that's a good reason for forming a
company together for a while like you
know the Fellowship of the Ring or
something we're both going to leave
fundamentalism together we're going to
help but it's not the basis for a
long-term marriage right it's not
of course you don't know this at the
time right the the kind the ways in
which you know I was foolish around this
are significant I was wrestling with a
lot of stuff I was wrestling with a
profound kind of depression I used to
call it the black burning in my chest
because of that whole like I said
I can imagine
but also like I said that there was
trauma
like there's instances like from when I
was still in it as a kid that were
absolutely traumatic to me I came home
one day I lived within walking distance
of the school and there was almost all
there was always somebody in the home
just because of the way it was a small
home we were a poor family there was
kids and you know my mom was mostly a
housewife
and I came home one and there was nobody
there
and I was absolutely convinced to my
bones that the Rapture had occurred all
my family had been taken away I was too
sinful I was left behind and the
Antichrist and his minions were coming
for me
this is like I'm 10.
and then another one I I used to read
the Bible every day and I'm glad I have
by the way biblical literacy is really
important part of Cultural Literacy I
don't begrudge that and the Bible still
is deeply meaningful to me but
I read this passage in the New Testament
where in multiple places they talk about
the unforgivable sin the sin that can
never be forgiven no matter how much you
pray about it and I was terrified and I
thought have I committed like I'm not
like again I think it was like 12. have
I committed the unforgivable sin and I
got like and and is thinking that the
unforgivable sin and all you know and I
was I got oh and my mother could tell I
was getting like I was getting deeply
distressed and she took me to the
minister
who was supposed to help me and he just
gave me empty platitudes that even as a
12 year old I recognized were completely
useless and I realized he doesn't have
an answer to this
he doesn't you know he pretended he had
it he spoke with the confidence of some
but there was no answer forthcoming
and it was just
like that kind of trauma and these are
these are just a couple instances of
many
and again I am not I'm not villainizing
my mom or my dad or my family I love
them
my mom and my dad are both dead I love
my extended family but
this is
when I stepped out of that
that now came to the fore like well
you've got to address this what is the
world such that right you shouldn't have
these fears you shouldn't have these
tears what do you do with the way that
has sort of made you afraid of things
like and so it yeah it took it took work
it took therapy it took meditation
contemplation Tai Chi Chuan
you know a lot of good education
especially in the socratic platonic
tradition
so that's what it was like I wouldn't
recommend it for anybody but the thing I
have to tell you Tim is I meet a lot of
people who are attracted to my work
because of something similar like this
happening to them they have left a
religious home and they they do not find
any religious homes viable yet they
still hunger for that deep connectedness
that meaning that space in which one can
cultivate wisdom